[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo it's your boy hardy caprio you
probably know me from the music that i
made but i can be a bit of a gamer so
5g tech has really changed the way i
play means i can game with my friends
even when i'm on the move
on tour or when i'm working late nights
in the studio
i used to love fifa i used to love
buddha carefree even like
sonic heroes all them sort of games
escapism so important but on the other
hand i'm also really competitive you
know i just love a challenge
and i love beating people at their
favorite game
it's so important to have a release and
a break from work you know gaming
definitely just helps keep me fresh and
in the creative headspace for when i'm
just
trying to write something new as a
creator myself i have a real respect for
the work and art that goes into making
the game
[Music]
we will face death and defend our home
i got this
who do you think you're talking to
[Music]
i know my destiny
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the 17th annual
british academy games awards from london
i'm your host ello silly wood and yes i
defeated a robust selection of
presenters
in combat for the privilege since 2004
bafta has celebrated games as an art
form
in their own right not just for their
capacity to engage
and entertain but to educate
to inspire to bring communities
together in a year marred by separation
both literal
and figurative games and the developers
behind them
have proven themselves to be more
essential
than ever in 2020 games connected us in
a way
that wouldn't have been possible a
decade ago
we built reasonably priced houses and
speculated on turnips in animal
crossing in doom eternal we stood
against the forces of hell
and in hades we fought alongside them
we tried to get good invalorant and get
the game to work
in cyberpunk 2077 whether squading up in
multiplayer
sharing a controller on the couch or
just talking about our favorite
titles online games brought us together
when we needed them
most tonight we honor
those games the people behind them and
the community they've inspired for the
second year in a row we've been
fortunate enough to hold these awards
virtually of course we're definitely
looking forward to when we can again
meet and celebrate in person but until
then we invite you to take advantage of
our digital platform
and engage with us in the comments
section a legendarily civil forum for
respectful clear-headed and hyperbole
free conversation
and after tonight's ceremony you can
also join us at twitch.tv
forward slash twitch gaming for our
after party show
where we'll be chatting to some of the
nominees for a more in-depth look
into the games that made 2020 worthwhile
in advance of tonight's proceedings we'd
like to extend
a heartfelt thank you to our partners
without whom this program would not have
been possible
to our friends at ee activision blizzard
electronic arts playstation sega
10 cent games and ubisoft we remain
immensely grateful for your continued
commitment to gaming advancement
and your support of the arts
we have an exceptional list of nominees
this year and we are so excited to
reveal the winners
as well as the ee game of the year award
and
this year's recipient of the bafta
fellowship
but before we start to celebrate these
incredible games
let's take a short look at what it was
like to be a developer
in 2020 and the challenges they overcame
on the road to release
[Music]
back in march when this started it came
as a shock to everyone you know across
our teams our development teams if you
had asked us how long would be gone
there you know there was guesses from
a month a few months you know no one
probably would have guessed a year
and i remember that time with the leads
we sat in a hall
and we were like what are we going to do
the viruses
looks like it's really here it wasn't
even being afraid of things it was more
like we have to act responsibly what's
the responsible thing to do here
in the space of two weeks everybody had
to change
we were fortunate in that we'd work from
home for for many years so
the the big kind of life-changing stuff
of working from home wasn't
so much an issue but of course there's a
million ancillary things i had people on
my team that were
literally like an ironing board was
their desk we had to do things like
send people's equipment home and that's
you know a bigger task than you realize
how are we going to be able to shoot
with our actors
and we came up with tricks on the set
like separating
actors with a plastic wall to make sure
they could still be
in close proximity without risking each
other's health
and just a general kind of mental health
challenge of
you know everyone's in a in a dark world
all of a sudden that's that's something
we
kind of had to work through with
everyone we made available
a counselor we just wanted to make sure
that if people felt
that they needed to reach out that they
could reach out
we also created a lot of space for
socialization
so we had morning coffee zoom and
yoga lessons twice a week and uh
game evenings you know when everyone's
kids are at home
uh often there's a significant other
kids would run in and kiss their parents
and tell them that they loved them and
it was just
it warmed us like we needed those human
moments and we kind of
celebrated and normalized those being
okay i think games have definitely
you know filled a gap in people's
schedules more for a lot of people
who've
maybe never touched them before or
haven't touched them for years there is
that sense of community there that has
kind of strengthened and
and brought people out of what is you
know what
has been a dark time that understanding
of the social
power of gaming has really you know
reached a broader audience and i think
that's gonna you know benefits us
all in the long term a lot more people
have been invited into the gaming
community
we have been able to um find a way
of forming a strong community
within each other and working with each
other to build something
great it's allowed for a greater talent
pool
to be able to access game development
whether that's because of their physical
location
working hours in a studio or physical
accessibility a lot of parents now
recognize
the more positive role and the positive
elements that gaming
plays in their children's lives we all
had an opportunity to do with more
introspection and to think about um you
know our place in culture and
our impact and how we can how we can be
part of positive change
we gave away over three million
uh copies of monument valley to to
people
stuck at home and we've helped plant
over half a million trees
as part of our alba tree planting
campaign
the game industry you know granted we're
not saving lives we're not making
vaccines and
you know those people are obviously the
true heroes of this entire thing
it's nice to know that the industry
played a part in making people happy
and helping them connect with their
family and friends and it
you know what a what an honor to be a
part of something like that
now tonight we're coming to you live but
after last year's brilliant acceptance
videos
some of the awards this evening will be
presented live while others
have been pre-recorded and taking
advantage of this virtual ceremony we're
excited to have our friends from the
worlds of
film television and games along to help
so here to present our first award for
game design
is the bafta fellow and industry legend
behind metal gear and death stranding
it is our privilege to welcome mr hideo
kojima
is
animal crossing new horizons
astros playroom
ghost of sashima
hades
[Music]
half-life alex
the last of us part two
i'm amir rao i'm the studio director for
supergiant games and i'm one of the
designers who worked on hades alongside
gavin greg alice and ed we want to thank
the bafta judges for this award we want
to thank
our team for all their support
we want to thank all the designers in in
the roguelike genre who who helped pave
the way for hades
and also to all of our fans and players
in early access who gave us feedback
to help hades become what it is today
thank you so much
it's often claimed that there are no new
ideas in
entertainment and while there's no
denying we love a reboot
our nominees for this next category
prove otherwise
here to present the award for original
property is the host of the hit
podcast how to kill an hour marcus
bronzy
whether we were madly careening across
candy floss inspired courses as sentient
beans or
ravenously consuming scientists as an
eldritch mass of bloody tentacles
our next nominees showed an incredible
capacity to imagine and execute new
ideas
the nominees for original property are
carrion
fall guys
ghost of tsushima
[Music]
hades
[Music]
kentucky route zero tv edition
[Music]
spirit fairer
and the bafta for original property goes
to
kentucky route zero tv edition
hi i'm jake elliott and i'm here
representing myself and also uh tomas
kamenci and ben babbitt the other two
guys from cardboard computer
and uh we just want to say thanks so
much it really means a lot to us this uh
recognition thank you so much for
considering us for this incredible honor
it means a lot for this work to be given
such a warm welcome i want to say thanks
to everybody who
you know played act 1 in 2013 or
whatever and
had the vision to say like it was a
little slow but maybe it'll get
interesting later or whatever it took
you know for you to stick with the game
for this whole time it's really uh
made a difference and thanks to
everybody at annapurna interactive for
helping us cross the finish line
and to all of our families for the
tireless support thanks so much
as motion capture technology advances
video games have become an ambitious
platform
for a host of extraordinary actors
not only have these next nominees shown
us incredible
human performances but they've done so
for hours-long
branching narratives all while staying
true
to the characters they portray our first
live presented award is for performer
in a supporting role and here to present
it
someone you may know as an actor in
netflix's sex education
or alternatively as the latest esports
recruit from
team liquid please welcome asa
butterfield
acting is reacting and that can be
difficult when your scene partner is a
tennis ball on the end of a stick
but these actors still manage to ground
their performances in humanity
nonetheless and so the nominees for
performer in a supporting role
are
carla slow deep breaths
your cortisol and adrenaline spiked but
the soft activated your hormone blockers
nothing happened
you're alive and well jeffrey pearce
forget about her
you sitting all comfy way out here
i'll make her pay tell me that's what
you said when we got back to jackson
tommy logan cunningham
who do you think you're talking to
nobody gets out of my domain whether
alive
or dead patrick gallagher
do you know how i prepared for today
i learned which villages to tame and
wish to burn
so i'll ask you once again samurai
do you surrender shannon woodward to sit
here and wait for you
for god knows how long just thinking
you're dead the entire time i don't plan
on dying
yeah well neither did jesse troy baker
somehow the lord gave me a second chance
at that moment
i would do it all over again
and the winner is logan cunningham as
hades
achilles poseidon asterius charon
and the storyteller in hades
oh my god um
wow uh thank you bafta
thank you for having
this category thank you for having an
acting category for games for
for so many years it's um it's it's it's
unique and it's important
and and it's awesome um thank you my uh
uh and i want to congratulate my fellow
nominees i want to
share this with the entire cast of hades
which
our wonderful cast of over a dozen
actors which includes actually my old
high school improv teacher uh peter
kenovesey who's
uh zeus and chaos uh mr c if you're
watching
congratulations uh supergiant games
uh drake gosavin our creative director
and writer thank you for writing this
game
and all these fantastic characters i was
able to play and for all the worlds
in in all the games that we've done amir
rao
thank you for giving me the job uh
over 10 years ago uh darren corb our
fantastic um
audio director and voice director i was
able to uh
i'm happy we were able to sort of dust
you off and
make you act again as zagreus fantastic
work
thank you um and amir and darren uh
thank you both for your
uh for your friendship
uh uh to everyone who's played hades
and turned it into the phenomenon that
it is we are
completely in your debt and uh without
you we would have nothing
else to do so uh thank you very much for
that this is a
huge this is a huge honor this is this
is huge for me
um for um from my father
thank you
our next nominees may not all have been
released in 2020
but they're here because they have
continued to provide engaging
exciting content and features that bring
definitive meaning to the idea of
games as a service presenting the award
for
evolving game please welcome renowned
esports presenter
frankie ward while many of us
love to explore every intimate detail of
a title through multiple playthroughs
these next nominees have held our
attention through consistent updates to
their games
that manage to engage delight and tell a
story
the nominees for evolving game are
destiny 2 beyond light
dreams
fall guys
fortnite
no man's sky
sea of thieves
and the bafta goes to sea of thieves
hey everyone bit weird to be recording
this video not knowing if we've won or
lost
if we have one amazing if we haven't not
so amazing but you won't be seeing this
video anyway but is that like a
bear accepting a bafta in the woods or
is it a tree falling in the woods i
don't know but
but anyway uh thanks so much for this
and it's a privilege to be here
representing our team who've done an
incredible job working on the game
evolving it over the last year during
these unprecedented times and it's been
great
to work on something our players can
escape and socialize it and i think it's
been really special
thank you so much uh just amazing and
congratulations to our team
uh and i'll just pretend to hold a
virtual award i'm sure we can cop that
in
oh isn't it nice
tonight wouldn't be possible without our
partner
ee the sponsor of our next category
the winner of which has been decided by
you the community
here to present the ee game of the year
is a beloved
game streamer and presenter please
welcome leviathan
thanks to everything everywhere we are
honoring gaming excellence in a year
defined by
some things some places here are the
nominees for ee game of the year
[Music]
animal crossing new horizons
call of duty warzone
hades
the last of us part two
[Music]
valerant
all of these nominees delivered
outstanding titles during a very
challenging year and while we honor them
all
we are humbled to present this award to
the winner chosen by you
the gaming community the ee game of the
year award goes to
the last of us part two
oh man um you know why i'm so nervous
uh thanks to bafta for selecting us
amongst
such wonderful games that we adore and
are inspired by
um congrats to everyone at naughty dog
everyone that worked on this game
um you know we made a game that pushed
us outside our comfort zone and finished
it under very
unusual crazy circumstances uh and yet
every single one of you delivered in
spades um
thank you to every fan that voted for us
your support encourages us to keep
taking risks and keep pushing ourselves
outside of that comfort zone so on
behalf of everyone
at nighty dog everyone at sony everyone
that worked on last was part two a big
hearty thank you thanks
2020 was the year that launched a
thousand hobbies
and while some learned how to bake the
perfect sourdough
channel their inner bob ross or simply
become one with a sofa
gamers shot off into space sailed
across oceans and flew around the world
so here are some of our favorite video
game moments
of 2020
i think in 2020 we've seen more people
who didn't previously think of
themselves as gamers suddenly
discover the benefits of this space 2020
was the year that gaming
became to the world what it always has
been this social experience that
connects people
straight away we were plunged into
quarantine and there was animal crossing
where you could go visit your friends
and go visit their islands my wife and i
were at a remote house
no internet around a fire pit glasses of
wine
and when we were like oh man it'd be
cool to be able to count down to the new
year what do we do
our first thought and our only thought
was animal crossing we had my little
character in a tuxedo
and with friends we had made we're there
to count down with us and watch that
together and turn and you know share a
kiss at midnight
you see people connecting over games and
using them for good and
using it to raise a lot of money for
charity we saw so much resiliency
especially from independent developers
getting games out in conditions where
you know you can't collaborate face to
face
i don't think i would be as chipper as i
am now if i didn't have
these groups of friends playing games
the moment that really literally made me
physically cry was the black girl gamers
online summit
that was so impactful to me
and to the audience that was watching
when travis scott on fortnite
put on the show astronomical a live show
in fortnight that the whole world could
tune into and over 12 million people did
realizing that we were still able to
have these massive tier one
tournaments and they still felt epic
among us turned out to be the social
experiment that
none of us thought we wanted but
definitely needed in our lives
covid kind of forced people to use games
to connect which is what gamers have
been doing for years
along with that came that chat about
diversity in this space because so many
more people were paying attention to it
it was really kind of that unique
cultural phenomenon that couldn't have
happened at any other time
like other storytelling mediums video
games bring us
experiences that move us from the raw
creative potential of dreams to the
somber
meditative moments of the last of us
part two
2020 brought us a wealth of games that
made us think
and made us feel here to present the
award for game
beyond entertainment please welcome
renowned education advocates
and mermaid expert sasha coward
the next category honors the games built
around the player experience that focus
not on getting the highest score
or killing the most baddies rather they
encourage players to think critically
creatively and immerse themselves in a
fully
realized world the nominees for game
beyond entertainment
are
animal crossing new horizons
[Music]
before i forget
dylan are you here
dreams
spirit fairer
tell me why if someone buys it they can
do whatever they want with it
you wouldn't care at all would you
the last of us part two just a girl
not a threat
[Music]
ellie
and the bafta goes to animal crossing
new horizons hello everyone i'm nicholas
wegnes
general manager for nintendo uk and
ireland and i'm extremely happy to
accept the award for
game beyond entertainment for animal
crossing new horizon
somehow communication was always an
integral part
of the idea the developers had for this
franchise in this game in particular
and we're extremely happy to see and to
have observed so many people
using this game to stay in contact with
their loved ones and
communicate through their gaming
experiences
we would like again to thank bafta for
this award and are extremely proud to
accept it thank you so much
the power of games lies in their ability
to immerse us
and sound design is a crucial part of
that
the soundscape of a game builds a world
and transports us
there our next live presented award is
for the team
that enriched the gaming experience
through masterful use
of audio here to present our award for
audio achievement
is award-winning composer emma noon
games have always drawn praise for their
achievements and their visuals
their ability to push a graphics card to
its limit
in order to build worlds that look even
better than the real thing
however ingenious sound design can take
the player from this world
and truly immerse them in the realm of
pure fantasy
where anything is possible the nominees
for audio achievement
are
astro's playroom
ghost off sashima because i can
hades
half-life alex they're going to find out
what he knows
and then they're going together marvel
spider-man
the last of us part two
the bafta goes to the ghost of tsushima
wow um sorry that was a surprise
um well first off thank you
to the academy and i also really want to
thank all of the other nominees because
each one of them
has been a huge inspiration for our team
to really
keep pushing ourselves and try to be
better
and also definitely want to thank nate
fox and jason cannell
and brian fleming chris zimmerman for
just giving us
this amazing property to work with and
of course my audio team here at sucker
punch josh lord michelle thomas michael
pitteniello
ty hastings and our incredible partners
at playstation
there's a lot to name but i'll try to
rattle them off real quick because i
think they all deserve recognition for
this
adam lidbetter mike niederkwell eric
glenn successos farbek rob castro andres
herrera
our amazing audio qa team there morgan
fryer mcculloch
jared chapman our music team andrew
baresh ted coker nick mastroyani
adam kolibjean sonia coronado monty mudd
uh kyle richards for on dialogue as well
as uh
uh phil kovats jeremy bullat uh
leilani ramirez pete scoturo keith leary
chuck dowd
and mark cinesack as well as our
partners at molinaire
and of course shigeru mabayashi and
ivanishkari for
music it was all such a collaborative
experience between all these people
and i'm just so proud of all of them and
thank you so much for this honor
animators exemplify the intersection of
art
and technology at the heart of games
frame by frame they painstakingly blend
classic technique with innovative tech
quite literally
bringing a game to life here to present
our award for
animation please welcome gaming host and
co-founder of kind of funny
greg miller if a picture is worth a
thousand words
then an animation is worth several
novels
these next nominees have managed to take
still assets
and turn them into living moving worlds
and characters
for everyone who has had to deal with
the foibles of maya and zbrush
this award belongs to you our nominees
for animation are
doom eternal the only thing they fear
final fantasy 7 remake
[Music]
the last of us part two i'm not gonna do
this again
i want what you want
[Music]
marvel spider-man miles morales
ori and the will of the wisps
[Music]
spirit pharah
and the bafta goes to the last of us
part two
it is such an honor to receive this
award and none of this would be possible
without the hard work of so many people
our animation teams are naughty dog and
basg who pour their heart in every
single frame
and to our dedicated team of actors and
athletes who gave us hundred percent
in every take to our teams of artisans
and engineers
who give us creators to bring life to
and the tools to mold them
and most of all to our loved ones who
provide support and encouragement to us
every step of the way thank you
this year most of us saw our world
shrink down to the same
four walls so it's no surprise that the
variety
and vibrancy of games has seemed more
enticing than ever
before artists define the visual
identity of a game
crafting stunning worlds which embody
the development team's collective
vision here to present this award please
welcome
bafta nominated actor and founder of
silver rain
games abubakar saleem
there are those who may dismiss games
themselves as inconsequential parlor
entertainment
now exercises in frivolity that pale in
comparison to film television
and theater disposable chocolaties to be
consumed and
discarded into the waste bin of
forgotten novelties
to those philistines we say with
conviction
nah see these games prove that not only
can games hold their own as an art form
but they can reach equal if not greater
height than the traditional media that
preceded them
now the nominees for artistic
achievement are
cyberpunk 2077. let's roll
[Applause]
dreams
[Music]
ghost of sashima
hades
[Applause]
half-life alex with you every step of
the way
you're gonna need a gun don't worry it's
unloaded
it's unloaded now the last of us
part two it's pretty right
hey you know what i'm gonna teach you
how to play guitar
and the bafta goes to hades
hi my name is gen z and i'm the art
director at supergiant games
on behalf of the art team here at
supergiant i want to thank the academy
for this
remarkable distinction to be nominated
alone
is such an honor
we are so so humbled a big thank you
to my industry peers uh fellow nominees
the artists that came before me and of
course the family friends and fans of
supergiant games
lastly i would be remiss if i did not
thank the ancient greeks
for their contributions to this project
thank you again everyone
video game technology has always been
the envy
of the arts world and in the last few
years they've started trying it
for themselves the royal opera house
used virtual reality to take
audiences inside opera the royal
shakespeare company used interactive
technology
to cast their midsummer spell and star
wars used a
game engine to create an entire universe
for the mandalorian
if you noticed it behind baby yoda that
is
of course we already knew that games are
at the forefront of artistic
technical innovation every nominee in
this category
has conquered code to create
transformative experiences
that belie the mathematical mastery
beneath
so here to present the award for
technical achievement
please welcome shoutcaster and esports
presenter
alex goldenboy mendez
from flight simulations to one man
vendettas against the forces of hell
from a road trip across a country
ravaged
by a fungal menace to well whatever is
going on
in demon souls and then dying and then
doing it over and over again the awe
striking breadth of experience that
these next games displayed speaks
to their development team's unique and
extraordinary capacity to execute
a creative vision the nominees for
technical achievement
are
demon souls
[Music]
doom eternal
[Music]
microsoft flight simulator
[Music]
marvel spider-man miles morales
the last of us part two i'm guessing the
military bombed this place
why would they do that sometimes
destroyed parts of the city that were
lost to the infected
and the bafta goes to
dreams
[Music]
[Music]
unfortunately it looks like we've lost
sound there
don't worry if you tune in to the after
party
we'll hopefully be able to get the
dreams team back there to have their
moment now from bafta initiatives like
breakthrough
and young game designers to year-round
games event programming
networking opportunities competitions
outreach and so much more bafta commits
itself
to the support and development of new
talent in games
as well as championing the craft of
games design
within the entertainment industries with
the bafta games awards
we intend not just to recognize great
achievements
but to inspire them as well it is our
enduring mission
to help create and support a more
diverse
inclusive and equitable games industry
both in the immediate future
and for years to come so let's take a
look at some of the highlights
from these initiatives
[Music]
bafta as an institution has always been
the forefront of
recognizing great accomplishments within
the video game industry
everybody spent four years trying to
make this game
so thank you
[Applause]
have a good night
i mean we're in quite a discombobulating
time
this really means a lot to us thank you
so much for being curious
welcome to this very special after event
welcome to this very special master
class the craft
of games writing the craft of game art
it seems like the wider world is
realizing something that we gamers have
known for a while
but games can help connect you with
others on a deeper level
[Music]
initiatives like ygd is so important
they help young people understand that
games are a viable career path
[Music]
this is such an amazing stepping stone
into the industry that i'd like to see
myself working in
next for me would be to continue
developing games
and to create a game for next year's
back the competition
kudos to all the winners and nominees of
the ygd awards this year
huge congrats to this year's winners and
nominees
we are basking in your golden globe be
creative be
bold be wonderful collaborators
[Music]
fortunately we are now able to hear from
the winner of
technical achievement dreams
hi oh technical problems in the
technical achievements award
so on behalf of everyone at media
molecule and our friends and colleagues
sony thank you so much um as with the
other nominees for this award we've
spent so many hours
doing exciting and challenging technical
work that's sort of hiding in the
shadows
with the goal to hide all of that that
work from the player
so we're so humbled to have this moment
to have the spotlight shine on us
and celebrate that work and most
importantly i want to thank the dreams
community
who've come on this this wild journey
with us i'm so excited to see where we
go next
again thank you
when you're stuck at home with your
family for 12
months straight every game becomes a
family game
so we couldn't be more grateful for the
developers working
with our relatives in mind and our next
category celebrates the games
that actually made us happy to spend
time squashed in the same room
our presenter for this award is a bafta
winning actress
who's appeared in game of thrones his
dark materials
and will be portraying ellie in the
upcoming last of us hbo
series please welcome bella ramsay
hi i'm bella and i'm honored to be
presenting this award
the titles that leave us vigorously
sending baddies into the suite hereafter
can be great fun but aren't particularly
suitable for family games tonight
thankfully these next games are as
wholesome as they are fun to play
and as easily shared with bloody
relatives as any tabletop classic
the nominees for family game are
animal crossing new horizons
astros playroom
dreams
[Music]
fool guys
[Music]
minecraft dungeons
[Music]
zack boy a big adventure
and the bafta goes to suck boy
a big adventure hi i'm joel smith and
i'm the art director of sat boy big
adventure
well thank you bafta this is fantastic
i'm so privileged to be accepting this
award on behalf of the incredible team
at sumo sheffield
who've worked tirelessly to create a
brand new adventure for sat boy
family was at the forefront of my mind
when creating this game and especially
in the last eight months
so here's the sumo family and all the
other families have enjoyed being part
of sac boys new adventure
so thanks again
you never get a second chance to make a
first impression something i'm keenly
aware of tonight
and our nominees in this category wasted
no time
in introducing themselves to the game
world in style
here to present the award for debut game
is the team
behind the brilliant podcast play watch
listen alana pierce troy baker
mike bithell and austin wintery
essentially it's like schrodinger i
think that uh i think
schrodinger said there's cats there's
some cats and then there's
definitely said no cats though that's do
you think schrodinger was a cat person
anyway with a dark dark history we
are play watch listen and we're
saying watch a bafta
oh right some developers merely knock at
the door and others
absolutely kick it down our next award
belongs to the studio who made their
first debut game while bringing their
a-game
the nominees for best debut game are
you video package
airborne kingdom
[Music]
call of the sea
[Music]
carrion
factorio
[Music]
the falconer
[Music]
rookie
and the bafta goes to carry
him hello i'm sebastian and karion is
our first game as an independent video
game studio
so we are amazed to see all the response
and the release was amazing
and now it's got the best debut award
and uh
it's incredible because it gives us
confidence and boosts our self-esteem so
we are looking forward to new
game design challenges thank you all and
stay safe games are
unique within the arts for their ability
to communicate an experience
across cultures and nationalities
a privilege that british game developers
are well aware of
so we thank these next nominees for
helping britain garner a reputation
for our world-renowned talent in game
design
and development here to present the
award for best game for british game
sorry please welcome the founder of
black girl gamers
jayanne lopez
reluctant though we may be to lean into
overt national pride
there is a time to celebrate the
contributions of british creatives
to the world of entertainment this
evening is one of those times
this time is limited to the next few
minutes so please set your watches
accordingly
with that said the next award is for
2020's british game
and the nominees are
[Music]
dreams
formula one twenty twenty
four guys
roki
[Music]
zack boy a big adventure
the last campfire
and the bafta goes to
sac boy a big adventure
uh thank you so much uh it's an honor to
be able to accept this award
on behalf of the team um there's a bunch
of people that i'd like to thank
uh first of all uh our fellow nominees
it's an outstanding selection
of titles to be nominated alongside um
but i
particularly like to thank media
molecule if it wasn't for their original
vision for like this wonderfully
endearing character and his handcrafted
world
our game simply wouldn't exist i'd like
to say a massive thank you to pete smith
tom o'connor all the people at sony xdev
you guys trusted us you supported us and
um
we couldn't have hoped for a better
development partner
on a personal note i would really like
to thank the team it's been a privilege
to work alongside such a talented
and dedicated group of people shipping a
game
is never easy um shipping a game in 2020
was its own unique challenge
and and you rose to that challenge um
finally
uh i'd just like to thank the players um
for everyone who went out uh
got a copy of the game and joined sakura
on his latest adventure
we really appreciate the support thank
you ever so much
when it comes to storytelling in games
music is an essential narrative element
just think of the utter unbridled panic
when you hear
unexpected boss music all the way it
feels when a score
crescendos to celebrate your success
a game soundtrack is inextricably linked
to the emotional experience of the
player
and the memories they take from that
world presenting
the award for music please welcome han
zuma oh
sorry um our producers are telling me
that the presenter for music is actually
the esteemed bafta winning composer
jessica curry
[Music]
well it's a telegram from mr zimmer
feet off the piano i told you
god's hands again hans is busy
he was supposed to be presenting the
music factor he's asked me for a favor
he wants me to present the music bafta
i couldn't possibly not dress like this
not with the studio in this state
hans we've been through some brilliant
times together
i'll do this for you
as tolstoy said music is the shorthand
of emotion
this has always been true in games music
can inspire joy
and playfulness it can instill suspense
and fear
and it can bring us to places revelatory
in some music has and continues to be an
essential component of great
games these nominees prove that that
tradition hasn't changed
the nominees for music are
[Music]
hades
[Music]
the last of us part two
marvel spider-man miles morales
[Music]
ori and the will of the wisps
zach boy a big adventure
and the bafta goes to marble spider-man
miles moranis my name is brian horton
and it's an honor to accept this award
on behalf of everyone at insomniac games
playstation marvel games and the many
talented actors and developers
who worked on marvel spider-man miles
morales we strive to make a positive and
lasting impact on people's lives
and miles morales lives up to these
ideals when he fights to protect harlem
and the people he loves
special thanks to our fans and our
families who support us
and bafta for this incredible honor
our next recipient joins the ranks of
industry
legends like shigeru miyamoto tim shafer
and hideo kojima since its inception
the fellowship award has been given to
gaming luminaries
who have made outstanding contributions
to the medium
visionary individuals who lead the
industry forward and redefine
what excellence in games can mean
to present the fellowship we are honored
to welcome a
true advocate of independent ambitious
creators
the co-founder of gorilla games who
headed
development of killzone and horizon zero
dawn
please welcome the head of sony
worldwide studios
home and host the fellowship
is the highest accolade that bafta can
be stolen
it's presented to an individual with a
substantial body of work
in recognition of an outstanding and
exceptional contribution to games
she already receives this award in
recognition of her pioneering work
advocating for diversity inclusion
and a creative and collaborative culture
she believes that games are the artistic
medium of her time
and the games industry should be a place
for all
as media molecules studio director she
has created a studio culture that has
produced some of the british games
industry's most beloved titles
and now in dreams the next generation of
creators have all the tools they need
to express themselves it is my
great honor to present the bafta
fellowship
to siobhan reddy
[Music]
my name is siobhan and i am the studio
director here at media molecule
which means i look into this and try and
predict the future
huge congratulations siobhan you are an
amazing
inspirational leader you've inspired a
whole team of molecules
to continue to push boundaries archival
and you're a force of nature without
whom
i think media molecule would have lasted
15 minutes but instead it's still going
strong after 15 years
whenever i see anything media molecule
related
my spirits are automatically lifted
and siobhan's influence is all over that
ocean
a partner in crime who i annoy almost
daily
but i know you know how much i really
care
you are teaching me the value of not
just sitting in the corner with
headphones on and being so grumpy
when i think about siobhan the thing
that i think about is her heart
and her accommodating spirit and how
every time i've been with her
not a single person that has come up to
her and asked her for advice or said
hello has she turned away
she's always given her full attention to
them we love working with students and
we love seeing what you guys are doing
a massively massively inspiring it's
hard for me to uh
summarize my feelings about siobhan
because
i think she's the person i admire most
in all the games industry she has made
such a positive contribution to
the art form and she's done so with
creativity
and integrity and good humor
ever since we met i've been inspired by
the love you have for connecting the
wider game development community
to care for the human beings that make
these games
and her vision to empower them is one of
her
many many incredible traits when i grow
up
i want to be siobhan ready siobhan leads
and inspires
some of the most creative people from
all over the world
and she does it in a way that appears to
be effortless
there is nobody more deserving of this
award than siobhan
she sees the best in people she makes
you want to be that best version of
yourself
so congrats to you this is overdue
i'm looking forward to seeing what other
magic comes from
[Music]
well done siobhan you've inspired a
whole generation
of game players and turned them into
game makers
and for that i think we will all be
tremendously thankful
i can imagine that siobhan will be
humble in receiving this award
she will say it's it's about the team
and not her but i think
at this moment it really is about her
congratulations
what an inspiration but a guiding light
what a fantastic person and a great
friend
no one deserves it more than you sean
congratulations shibon and lots and lots
of love
i hope you're having a splendid evening
and that we get to celebrate this award
in person very soon i can't wait till
we're outside of these boxes and
can give each other a big old hug
congratulations siobhan from a
very wet and wild day in sydney
we couldn't be more proud of you down
here your games have bought so much joy
to so many people
as to you my friend i just want to thank
siobhan
for everything she's done we are so
lucky to have you um
and the world is a better place for you
being here i cannot wait till you can
make it back over to australia and we
can celebrate again
over a coffee or an espresso martini
shivan congratulations on this very
well-deserved
recognition please keep on being a force
of nature
congratulations on your bafta fellowship
siobhan
thank you siobhan thank you for all the
support you've given us and
i miss you mate i can't wait for that
next line anya
thank you for being such a great friend
over these years and
congratulations on your bafta fellowship
which is richly deserved not just
because of the games you've made
but because of those ways that you've
helped all of us
myself included and lifted us up along
the way
wow um it was a really amazing video
thank you
everybody um i have so many people to
thank
um my career is a total team effort dave
is totally right
um and you know it's currently still a
work in progress
um i have actually felt quite strange
about accepting this award
and because my crew has been filled with
you know the highs and the lows and
stakes and the successes and describe
this once
as this sort of feeling of like the
glitter and doom that we feel on this
roller coaster of
games development tonight is definitely
a lot of glitter and i'm really great
really so grateful
um i first have to thank my family
watching from australia and south africa
um they are a brilliant bunch of people
who've always provided
inspiration and in fact um my career
actually started in my parents shoe shop
when i was 12.
and that shop was more than a shoe shop
it was a little community and i apply so
much of what i learned there to media
molecule and to my life
alex mark kareem dave gemma and abby
working with you is the highlight of my
career and to the rest of media molecule
thank you for everything you are my
inspiration i couldn't
imagine a nicer more creative more
interesting lovely group of people
we've had ups and we've had downs
together and we've weathered a few
storms
i'm so proud of what we have achieved
with dreams and i'm excited to see where
we take things in the future
it's community you bring me immense joy
i love your creativity and you are why
we do this
to sony especially to scott and to
hermann i'm very excited about the
adventure that we are on together
my boyfriend barry he has the most worn
out ears and the biggest heart
he has loved me and mentored me
constantly and made me
spectacular lunches all throughout last
year lots of love to the meads as well
i love seeing people's creative take on
life and the world
i love hearing watching playing and
looking at their works
heading up a studio focused on giving
people the powers to do that
is totally my jam technology and
creativity
are for all of us this industry is
somewhere that should be attractive and
open to all who have an interest being
inclusive
makes us better bringing a wider range
of perspectives backgrounds emotions and
experiences to the table
creates media that is more considerate
more varied
more interesting and more powerful as
part of the media we affect the
collective cultural consciousness
in the way that we include and represent
society in our work
so the opportunity is missed when
inclusion isn't a priority
a medium is so powerful everyone out
there you are all
so powerful let's keep learning and
being thoughtful and considerate and
making changes
this industry has changed a lot since i
started in it
i have no nostalgia for the games
industry of the past
i only have plans and hopes and
excitement for the future
there are many doing great work way way
more than me
and it makes me so happy as it shows how
progressive we can be
we have a lot more work to do when it
comes to fostering an industry that is
inclusive
and where all people can thrive it can
be overwhelming to know how to start to
make a change
and so just take a baby step you have to
all start somewhere and for me my focus
has been media molecule and i love every
second of it
i have benefited from a lot of privilege
throughout my life
a lot more than others my family my home
working for women in the formative years
of and all of the help that i've had an
encouragement that i've had along the
way
it's really important for me to
acknowledge that that is how i've got
here
so with this fellowship i can guarantee
for this fellowship by the way
look at that how cool is that um
i can guarantee that this is not a full
stop
very much a work in progress and i have
more to live up to with this and it is
just the beginning of a new chapter
thank you for the motivation bafta and
to anyone out there who's interested in
joining in
our amazing industry please come along
for the ride it's a wonderful wonderful
place
where we get to put our dream take the
dreams from our head and put them out on
the screen
yeah thank you and thanks for that video
that was amazing thank you
what a wonderful choice for the bafta
fellowship congratulations
cheval now it's safe to say
2020 was quite the year from being stuck
at home
to being stuck at home to that exciting
moment when we realized
we were once again stuck at home so
while tonight has been about looking
back
let's take a moment to look ahead
what are you most looking forward to in
2021
[Music]
i think as a result of everything we've
experienced in 2020 now going into 2021
the gaming audience is going to be a lot
more widespread i think we'll just see
different types of people
and i'm not just talking about ethnicity
and nationality i'm talking about ages
as well
this can be a community hub this can be
just you
fostering adult relationships when you
don't want to get on the phone we're
going to continue seeing people
coming together and enjoying spending
time together
with with gaming as a companion
for me when you think about innovations
in 2021 it's pushing the technology we
already have further i'm excited to see
this
race to figure out cloud streaming
what's nintendo got in the bag
there are so many rumors about a switch
pro i
do think that the future is very bright
for virtual reality gaming
[Music]
there's a bunch of titles that i'm
looking forward to being released
for me a big one is alden ring love back
for bloods beta i'm so ready to have
some nice with my friends the mass
effect legendary edition
can't wait to play deftly please can
that when is that being released i need
that in my life
when i finally do get to go back to a
live event the first thing i'm going to
do and the first thing i want to be
excited to do
is run up to that game it's just getting
the map i'm going to plan it my whole
day
finding and meeting the people who
ordinarily you wouldn't meet outside of
them
and then bonding over the shared
experiences of course the first thing
i'm going to do is sanitize my hands
afterwards it's going to be hands-on
hands-on hands-on
hands-on poking in every nook and cranny
and seeing what's there that's how you
find
cool little booths cool little games
that you don't necessarily have on your
radar i just want to go
find the people that i love in this
industry
and give them a hug and say we got
through this
i welcome you with open arms come and
join us and game
video games offer up the chance to live
a
thousand different lives to genuinely
walk or sprint or crouch in someone
else's shoes
and whether we're defeating valkyries
playing an
amnesiac detective or romancing aliens
it's the narrative that captivates us
and turns a story
into an adventure presenting the award
for narrative is a voice acting legend
an award-winning actress who can be
heard in everything
from metroid prime to mass effect please
welcome
jennifer hale
man this night is making me fall in love
with our industry just
a million times deeper what an honor to
be here
all right storytelling is one of the
oldest traditions we have
a means by which we can understand and
experience without living it
games like all media give us a chance to
experience a story
in a new way these next games
transported us to
powerful storytelling during a year when
we needed it most
the nominees for narrative are
assassin's creed valhalla the fight is
mine
cyberpunk 2077
the khan deserves to suffer
stupid boy i told you nobody gets out of
here whether alive or dead
kentucky route zero tv edition marvel
spider-man
miles morales get them far away
i can't hold this in much longer
and the bafta goes to
80s hey i'm gregor savin writer and
creative director at supergiant games
and i am
deeply honored to accept this award
thank you so much to the academy
uh with hades we wanted to bring to life
uh some of our favorite gods ghosts and
monsters from greek myth
uh in a new way though we couldn't have
guessed
uh how much they would resonate with so
many of you out there
um i'm so grateful to darren korb
gen z and amir rao at supergiant for
working with me so closely
on portraying these characters on
getting them right and
to everyone at supergiant all our fans
and especially our families
and for their undying support throughout
development thank you
this year we felt more grateful than
ever
for the incredible evocative
performances in games
not least because choosing dialogue
options totally counts as a conversation
acting in video games is a demanding
discipline
calling for performers to use their
voices and physicality
in a way unlike any other medium here to
present the award for performer in a
leading role is an actor you may know
from the haunting of bly manor
or from his work in gears of war 5.
please welcome rahul kohli
acting is more than simply pretending to
be a character it's about embodying a
role and breathing life into it
showing a character's vulnerability
their wants and needs their strengths
and weaknesses and above all else
serving the story a great actor can keep
us from ever even seeing them at all
rather we get to witness a fully
realized character experiencing a
reality foreign to our own
but with such truth and commitment we
the audience are able to empathize and
relate with a journey
that will stay with us for a lifetime
the nominees for performance in a
leading role
are
[Music]
ashley johnson tell me
what happened here
if you lie to me one more time
i'm gone
[Music]
we had a leak my boss called dragged me
in because we had to
intervene everyone at night city hq is
on edge
cody christian you okay okay
yeah made it through with just a
couple of scrape knees back then
back then what do you say
are we doing this convince
your people to join me and i will give
them peace we will never
serve you
laura bailey then i need you to show us
to those boats
we don't let anybody stop us okay
okay naji jita i promise
to do everything in my power to protect
this city
i promise
[Music]
and the bafta goes to laura bailey
oh no oh man oh
thank you bafta that feels really
surreal to
say that um uh all my fellow nominees
i love you guys i i am so grateful to be
considered amongst
all of you very talented humans uh
uh troy baker you're a pillar in my life
and you will continue to be until we are
covered in wrinkles and
jaded uh to ashley
i see wings every time i look at you you
are
a beautiful talented angel um
to the entire cast and the whole team at
naughty dog thank you
for for
putting your heart and soul and
commanding excellence
for five plus years i wouldn't be making
this speech
if not for all the work that you guys
put in
neil druckmann and hallie gross thank
you for being
fearless in your storytelling for um
for writing a character who is
unexpected and honest and for
allowing her to be vulnerable without
precluding the fact that she could also
be a powerhouse
um to travis and ronan you're in the
other room i'll come give you a hug in a
second
all to the fans to the fans
thank you to everyone who has been
affected by this game
to everyone who loves these characters
as deeply as we do
it was such an honor to play abby and it
is such an honor to win morning
so much
our penultimate award tonight celebrates
games
that have answered the eternal call when
are we getting multiplayer whether
you're inviting
friends over to admire your stylish new
home or
dragging a friend into slime as payback
for stealing
your crown these nominees have innovated
new and
fun ways to bring us together or
drive us apart either way we're happy to
introduce our next presenter
for multiplayer named by new york
magazine
as one of the most powerful drag queens
in america please welcome trixie mattel
the very nature of games indicates the
participation of
other people multiplayer games give us a
chance to connect and compete
what is a game without multiplayer the
answer is very simple
it's single player the nominees for
multiplayer game
are
animal crossing new horizons
deep rock galactic
four guys
ghost of tsushima
[Music]
sackboy a big adventure
[Music]
valorent
and the bafta goes to animal crossing
new horizons
hello everyone watching from home i'm
nicholas wagnes general manager for
nintendo uk and ireland
and on behalf of the development team at
nintendo i'm extremely happy to accept
this award for best multiplayer
animal crossing new horizon is a game
that you can of course enjoy on your own
but is
even more fun when you share the
experience with friends
family members when you visit each
other's island
you show what you created and somehow
you enjoy
socializing through this video game
we're extremely happy and thankful for
this award and like of course to
thank bafta for this
now before we present our final award
we want to take a moment to acknowledge
how the gaming community
has come together in an incredibly
challenging
time there's no denying that 2020 was
a landmark year for games we launched
the next generation of ambitious new
consoles
and saw innovative titles set new
standards
in design and of course we've welcomed
more players than ever before
into our community and watched as the
world of games
worked its immersive transformative
magic
on millions but that isn't to say
it hasn't been hard most of us have
struggled through
a year of separation uncertainty
and loss and as such a social and
collaborative industry
creating games over video calls and
messaging services has been
an immensely tough ask
every single game that launched this
year was a triumph
a testament to the resilience of our
field
and the importance of our craft
this year has also been a reminder of
how fortunate we are to be
an industry and a community that
transcends
boundaries and fosters connection
video games have always been open to all
a joyful invitation to adventure
no matter who or where you are
we've always known just how vital that
sense of connection is
and gaming is built around it no
surprise then
that our community has become a refuge
for so many
however with that reach comes
responsibility
this year the world has opened its eyes
to the profound
potential games offer not just as
escapism
but as a space to bring friends and
family together
as educational tools that see students
wander through ancient greece
or learn to code as they play
and as an art form that offers immersive
expansive experiences no other medium
can match and in this brave new world
where
members of congress stream on twitch and
late night talk shows take place
in game each one of us is an ambassador
for this industry each of us has a role
to play
in ensuring that the games industry
builds on the inclusivity
we've seen this year whether that's
welcoming new players
seeking out diverse voices or
accommodating
different needs so tonight
let's take a moment to recognize our
incredible
community and the year we've made it
through
whether you launched a game or simply
finished playing one
tonight is a celebration of games
and the power they have to unite us
and now to present our final
award please welcome wwe superstar
and new host of g4 xavier woods
2020 was an incredible year for the art
form that we call video games
these nominees fully embody the spirit
of the gaming world by in their own way
adding to this beautiful collage that we
already know
and love so much and also by breaking
new ground and redefining
what entertainment really can be the
nominees for best game are
animal crossing new horizons
ghost of sashima
[Music]
we will face death and defend our home
hades
[Music]
half-life alex really picking up
they know you're coming you need to get
out of here
marvel spider-man miles morales
the last of us part two
and the bafta goes to hades
[Laughter]
on behalf of our whole team thank you so
much to the judges
we really really really appreciate this
uh thank you to
our partners at epic nintendo and valve
who helped us find an audience and thank
you to the audience
itself who basically helped make hades
what it became
in early access we really really
appreciate you and uh
you know for your support in allowing us
to stay together to make games
for a long time to come uh finally we'd
just
like to thank all the other games
nominated
tonight and and for their inspiration
and for providing a refuge for us
when we were finishing hades we we
really really appreciate it
and personally um thank you you know to
all our families
uh you know i've been working with uh
gavin
andrew greg darren logan and jen
since the very beginning that's the
group of people who worked on bastion
all four of these games together
we've added so many important voices
since then um but
uh it's just amazing to see your work be
celebrated in this way tonight i love
you all so much i love working with you
thank you again to the judges for for
for for this
i really appreciate it thank you so much
well that's it a huge congratulations
to tonight's winners and to our nominees
whose efforts would have stood out as
incredible in any
normal year making their achievements
against the challenges of
2020 that much more laudable
once again we'd also like to thank our
partners
ee activision blizzard electronic arts
playstation sega tencent games
and ubisoft most of all however
we'd like to thank you for joining us
here
at the 17th annual british academy games
awards
coming up please tune in to twitch.tv
forward slash twitch gaming for our
after party show where we'll be
chatting with the nominees and winners
from tonight's ceremony
but for now i'm elle o'silly wood
and it has been a pleasure to celebrate
with you
this evening before we let loose and
head to the after party
we'll leave you with a few words from
the chair of bafta
christian endu majumda i'm krish
majumder chair of bafta and thank you
for joining us for this year's
celebration
of the very best in games this evening
we recognise the standout games of 2020
a year in which people have enjoyed
playing games more than ever before
these are the ones that got us talking
that connected us with our families and
friends
that reduced our anxieties about what's
happening in the world
perhaps they help change how we look at
things seeing the world from a different
perspective
and of course the games we love playing
just for the sheer fun of it
these are the best as voted for by bafta
members and juries
thanks to all our loyal partners who
continue to support bafta
and our work with the next generation of
talon and thanks so much to elle for
hosting our awards tonight
it's been a difficult year for so many
of us but let's take a moment to
celebrate our tenacious and resilient
industry
and let's congratulate every one of our
bafta nominees
the people who've pushed technology to
its limits and expanded the artistic
horizon of this thrilling medium
join us now for a special after party
hosted by ether wilson and julia hardy
details on the screen below see you
[Music]
there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you